in string theory proper there are many
versions of the theory that do give rise
to other forces for the most part these
forces aren't manifest at the energy
scales that we have access to so they
would only come to life if you will if
you're probe in the universe on
incredibly short distance scales or
incredibly High energies but the other
answer is look if you have additional
forces that most of the particles that
we know about are immune to then those
forces won't have a whole lot to act
upon that we have observational insight
into so can you have additional forces
that persist even at low energies in
principle yes now there are bounds that
come to this mostly From cosmological
perspective because there's a limit to
the number of degrees of freedom that
you can have commensurate with the
expansion rate of space and things of
that sort so is it possible that there
are extra forces absolutely